[Music]
hey hi hello everyone welcome back to
the lobby GameSpot's weekly video game
hangout here every Wednesday in San
Francisco I'm your host Mike McCarty
here with quite an eclectic crew today
compared to normal Rob you're you're
always odd what's going on
not a whole lot Kelly's here but I think
she or at least on the airport around
the way to the airport
soonish right I don't know but Kelly is
out she's going up to place and destiny
I don't know if we're allowed to tell
people that but there you go Pete Brown
is not feeling well he is under the
weather he's got a few things he's
working from home on this is Michael hi
um hi hi
you got some hands-on time with the Xbox
one ex recently sure did so we brought
you on to talk about that oh no quick
quick thought before we go to Jake and
the news and stuff about 1x yeah one
word to describe it
powerful no don't say that oh I was on
last week I'm back you played horizon
zero down the frozen wild call Duty
World War two I got next and you got an
Xbox one I hope but you spent all night
downloading updates you didn't get the
try it yet yes I mean unless you count
like scrolling through the dashboard
trying it then we'll talk about I want
to ask about the dashboard and stuff
soon and Rob you spent a day at EA in
Redwood Shores playing battlefront huge
multiplayer so we thought more about
that yeah first as always want to get to
some news we do have a giveaway I'll
talk about later in the show as always
uh first off last week
Blizzard showed off overwatch is a new
character more Moira the support
character who also does healing who
heals and does damage she is on PC
public test realm right now if you want
to go check her out but they showed off
as per usual this team they showed off
the actual kind of cinematic trailer
mixed with gameplay of her here you see
Joey and tight right around a stream
I didn't hear whether they liked her or
not I know like Joey said he liked doom
fest the most recent edition but yeah if
you wanna go try out Moira or check out
it actually you know what check out our
video first before I was talking Joey
and player to resident overwatch experts
I'd say I was talking to Joey about when
they announced it I was like you think
they'll announce character he's like no
it hasn't been leaked yet oh yeah which
is right because all the other ones
right have been leaked through these
like Arg stuff right Sombra was like all
those hacking
teasers doom fist was been had been like
teased then in game maps throughout the
weeks leading up to his announcement and
Moira kinda just came out of nowhere at
Blizzcon which that was like probably
the biggest news from the show
aside from world of warcraft classic
which you know I maybe I'll finally get
into a world of warcraft with this seven
years later how many years more than ten
thirteen thirteen thirteen years of
World of Warcraft mm-hmm yeah thirteen
so yeah you can go back and play that
out what is the battle for Azeroth is
the that's the new expansion yeah cool
and also if you were kind of surprised
that a new Need for Speed game was
coming out like I was we have a review
up for it on GameSpot if you want to go
check that out our need for speed
payback
review is up I believe two to tomb oh no
we had a freelancer from the UK wrote it
but yeah it doesn't seem like it's that
great of a game we keep it alive out of
10 which means mediocre which means not
that great it's interesting because the
last time I heard about this game I
think was III yeah that's a lot of
people are saying it's like wait what
this saw at e3 and then
oh snap it came out yeah not a lot of
awareness around its release at least on
Iran but yeah you can go check out the
more in-depth review by freelancer
Richard way cling and we will be may be
talking about that more in the coming
days I probably won't have the chance to
play it but there you have it also
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 is coming to
zelda tomorrow thursday november 10th is
that it is that correct yes no November
9th apologies I have no sense of time
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 there's a new
side quests the free side quest going to
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
tomorrow if we can finish it you get
Rex's outfit from Xenoblade Chronicles
tuning upcoming RPG on switch I think
I'm more excited about the side quest
look at the expression on Lynx faces
like look happy mom take it he looks
like Randy we're gonna fit on the often
Christmas story did they say what the
psyche was is gonna consist of it all or
just no I have no I don't think so ok
it's free to write yeah yes his not
playing it at all with like Peter scream
um if Peters fill-in not under the
weather I think we're
we'll do lava sure above the weather
weather I think we'll play that tomorrow
and just post like a let's play or
something like is it because that game
is fun and I like playing Zelda a lot
like a lot I think you're the only one
yeah in the world four hundred and
ninety five hours least last time I
checked yeah I do
December correct DLC
I don't know i pre-ordered all those
amiibos I can't remember if did you
really know yeah well yeah just to see
what they do I got what are their names
[ __ ] diruk Ravalli your Bosa and or Bosa
yeah I got those they look really cool
person but I like those yeah those look
great their boats is like huge
they had Walter buca's too but I
definitely want Ravalli we don't work
cool they're way cooler looking than
they weren't winwaker they were like
those little toad looking bird things
and to end on some bad news
unfortunately Perfect World
Entertainment shuttered runic games if
you're a fan of torchlight 1 or 2 2 like
I am fantastic dungeon crawler loot fest
Allah Diablo 3 I actually think it's
better than the Apple 3 in a few ways
and they made the more recent hobb runic
games was shuttered and based on what
perfect world was saying it sounded like
they're kind of restructuring things to
go for that game as a service I think
more in future months and years
unfortunately so best of luck to all the
people that worked on tour slay one too
and hob I didn't get a chance to play
hot but I heard it was pretty good you
know like our best wishes go out to them
and that's some bad news to hear but one
more time before the end of the show
actually I want a pin bar extra live
stream we on November 17th starting at
noon we're gonna start our 72 hour
livestream between the u.s. office the
UK office and the Australia office for
the extra life charity for Sick Children
and we are gonna be playing pub G we're
gonna be playing Smash Bros we're gonna
be probably eating some disgusting stuff
for donations I'm thinking of maybe
doing some XCOM to in some respects like
maybe if people donate like $5 I'll make
them a character and a playthrough and
then see how long they survive
Rob's already bored yeah so John Luke is
heading up planning for that so
I think we're having one final meeting
like later this week and then we'll
we'll have more concrete announcements
and a page and we might do a little more
of an announcement kind of later this
week / early next week but November 17th
until November 20th noon until noon stop
by we'll see you there cool so we'll
just jump into segments
first off horizon zero dawn has the
frozen wilds DLC it is out now expansion
I'd say mhm
Jake you spend a lot of time with it I
spent a little bit of time with it I
didn't finish the expansion I think I
have a different perspective on this
because I only ever played like five
hours of horizon in February Oh real and
that fell off it Jake you beat the game
played a lot of it and then went back to
the expansion hey Richard
while you're in here can you turn off
our I'm hearing our audio thank you
sorry but yes you yourself were actually
you played a lot of the game early this
year now you're returning to it so first
off I want to kind of get into from a
lot of people's perspective this is a
tough game to relearn complex combat I'd
say kind of difficult but did you have
any of that experience yes so I was
talking to Peter a little bit about this
news like oh that's an easy game to jump
back into and I was like really and it
is in a sense because the world is
beautiful
the the setting is great halo is a great
character all that stuff is awesome but
when it comes to the combat it can be
tough to remember what's good against
what what weapons you should be using
here how these work so then and how to
do that quickly right and how did ya cuz
I mean you have to react fast in this
game and the symbols of the one you want
to call it the symbols of the ammo types
I confused like hard point precision
arrows hunter arrows a kind of lost
track with all those work yeah same with
me it was there there was definitely a
little bit of a curve that I had to
relearn however once you get the hang of
it again it's it feels so good the
gameplay in this game is top-notch like
it is I I wasn't wild about the story I
thought it was entertaining but just
being able to get back in there and
fight some of these giant machines is so
satisfying like they added the the it's
a grizzly bear it's called a frost claw
something like that but it's essentially
like a grizzly bear and it's like this
towering beast that's insanely fast and
its weak spots are on its back there's
some on its stomach but like
I mean you just sprinted him and slide
under its leg slowdown time and like
shoot underneath it turn around she gets
back it's you feel like such a badass
man I yeah there are so many fond
memories I have this game where it's
like speaking on like I guess I want to
even say that it's like elemental
different types right like you and
you're crafting and you're like I
remember like okay I need to create Lea
like a hard point Spears like that well
I have to go out to here and stalk and
bushes and then we finally seed it you
know said creature there is something
it's so gratifying to harpoon them and
you know yeah staple that into the
ground like that there is such an
enjoyment with like hunting likes those
is I think the rope cast or whatever
like I love it when there's one of those
giant birds and it lands and you just
pin that thing to the ground and then
you start hitting them hard point arrows
or whatever I for those who don't know
the frozen wild is a whole new area
called the cut way way north architect
kind of snowy vibe as you can see new
monsters wanna get into that but how
easy was it to kind of jump into this
new area the expansions actual content
from the main game um so first you have
to be I think it's level 30 level 32 I
should know so there's like a boss fight
right at the beginning to kind of level
yeah right yeah so you're supposed to be
like level 30 level 32 but actually
getting there apart from like I don't
know kind of like reorienting yourself
it's pretty easy and it's seamless to
okay so it's not like I don't like fall
out kind of did that a lot where it's
like here's a new area then you get on a
boat and it loads into a new area this
is actually you can essentially just
walk there um you do have to go through
like tunnels and climb some stuff but
it's cool how seamless it is and once
you get in there you visit a town and
then the world opens up
it's not huge but I mean it's dotted
with plenty to do yeah it doesn't sound
like it's blood and wine which are three
sides but it's definitely an entirely
new area a new kind of a new biome I
mean there was snow stuff in the main
game but this seems like way more of the
Arctic 5 yes it looks gorgeous and I
Peter played on the ps4 pro I've been
playing on the regular ps4 and I think
it looks stunning and then I was looking
at his game plan it looks even better
like it is still a beautiful game the in
general
kind of
we won't go into spoilers for what
happened in the main game for those just
joining a youtuber twitch
this is horizon zero dawn the frozen
wilds expansion this is out as of
yesterday was it yeah came out Tuesday
yes so this is out so you can play this
now but yeah my main question is and I
kind of already touched on this but as
someone who played a lot of the game a
is this returning is this worth
returning to and then be I guess for
someone like myself I think I could
speak more to this whether it's it
serves itself well if you're just
getting into the game but Jake from your
perspective do you think this is worth
returning to considering all the other
games that people might be catching up
on or is this like a second chance for
horizon almost for people who might have
missed out because it was a packed
spring I that's interesting I don't
think I I think it's worth returning to
this game definitely it is it is a
packed fall right now and it can be
tough to do that there's so many other
great games out but I think if you
haven't bought a lot of these games like
Wolfenstein Assassin's Creed whatever if
you're waiting for the price to drop
this is only $15 and getting back into
this game is so much fun and like the
gameplay still is is top-notch
so I would say yes it's worth going back
into unless you know you have a stack of
games you're trying to get through then
maybe maybe it's not worth it but one
thing Peter was saying was that playing
it made him want to do a New Game+ which
after playing more of it I really want
to do that as well if I had the time so
I think it's a good excuse
- honestly start the game over if you
liked it as much as I did and just kind
of play through the game and the new DLC
fits in much better that way I think as
opposed to like being at the end of the
game and then kind of taking this meat
or yeah because it's not it doesn't
actually factor into the overall main
narrative arc right all right factors
into it but it's not gonna like largely
affect it if you yeah it's like a side
story that I mean yeah it's not it's not
that important to the think it may be
right I mean like another example that
I'm thinking of was dead space threes
DLC that just completely changed the
ending of not just dead space 3 but the
trilogy and I if you haven't played that
by any chance and you should because
visceral just closed and those that
trilogy is worth playing
I remember that DLC actually changed the
ending of the trilogy and
like they were like oh [ __ ] we should
change a little bit to actually open up
the possibility of another game or
something like that obviously that won't
happen at least under visceral now but
horizons yard on presumably will see a
sequel at some point it did really well
for gorilla a friend Daniel Dwyer was in
Amsterdam yesterday he's shooting a
documentary about the making of the game
going from killzone to horizon it's one
of those cool stories about a studio
just completely pivoting what they were
doing and nailing it horizon didn't
really you know register with me earlier
in the year but from my perspective
coming into the dlc now what you were
saying I think it fits in really well is
someone who only ever played five hours
of the bass game now that this is a part
of it I hit like level 30 and I went
right up to fight whatever the robot was
I forget what they were called and it
felt like it fit in really well cuz once
I finished that I went back to do all
the late game main story stuff and it
fit in well and I would say I do see
this kind of as a second chance for
horizon for people who might have been
busy with neo or resonable 7 or I don't
know what else came out gravity rush - I
mean Zelda Zelda Zelda it was like a
week after right yeah that that's
probably the main thing that pushed me
off of it it definitely does now that I
think of it thank you yeah a lot of
people here cuz I I think it was you who
had it before and then we got switches
and you're like I have to put this aside
so I took it kind of well at that time
you're like I have to check out Zelda
which turned into 495 oh [ __ ] what
happened I mean but I knew what I was
doing I knew I was gonna get lost and
that was like yeah yeah I mean so that
so it's nice to see this I mean
obviously like resonable 7 has DLC
coming out December this is coming out
there's other stuff coming out - there's
more DLC expansions that kind of release
later in the airline then Zelda Ballad
camp it's like as if we need another
reminder that Zelda came out this year
but it's I think it's a good like Game
of the Year primer for people who are
really into that stuff while I'm on that
topic we are starting our stuff at the
end of the month I think we'll be making
all our announcements December at some
point for people who again who care
about GameSpot stuff agent mayhem right
that's like highest on the oh yeah
the lobby gaudí you bring that up all
the time
so horizon zero dawn the frozen wilds
you'll see that's a mouthful it is out
now from gorilla games on the
PlayStation 4 as of Tuesday November 7th
so you can go check that out if you
haven't played the game yet I highly
encourage you to check it out if you
have played the game as Jake said it's
worth returning for so there you go
cool the newest call duty installment
hoo boy yeah I think we all played this
yep so rather than me and Jake just
chatting Rob you played some of the
campaign last night finally you've been
two and a half of missions for campaign
I did play a good amount of the
multiplayer beta but I would imagine
it's not too different for context if
somehow you don't know this is the first
year that Call of Duty's going back to
World War two since call of duty world
at war which Treyarch made but the year
before that was called today for minor
warfare from Infinity Ward kind of when
it pivoted off of its World War 2 routes
ever since 2003 once you know Jason west
Vince Zampella broke off from the Medal
of Honor team to make the Medal of Honor
killer codename game became Call of Duty
as you can see here it sets the tone for
what in my opinion is a very clichéd by
the books World War 2 game looks
gorgeous as you can see here you got
Josh Duhamel you got the dude from the
black Donnelly he's a very short live TV
show which I seem to be the only one who
remembers he plays as US men you're your
comrade the other way anyway you're on a
landing boat you jump off the side you
go storm Omaha Beach you'd clear some
machine-gun nests how many times have we
done this before that was good
thanks I thought that was actual game
audio Rob what did you what did you text
me last night after playing two more
missions well I mean like what today and
I could pull my phone your overall
sentiment my overall sentiment was what
you were kind of addressing just now is
that cliche but just the tropes I mean
cliche like it's it to me it's it's like
so heavy-handed Saving Private Ryan in
like every action of what you're doing I
mean you're hopping over to the side of
the boat here you're doing bangalore's
and then just the dialogue in general
I guess where I was in says I found like
there are certain characters in this
game I guess I don't want spelt so much
that they the lines are so cliche and
tropi to like Old World War 2 lingo and
stuff and attitude that it doesn't fit
the plot this character here you're
looking at on the right is what I'm
alluding to we're like sergeant Pearson
sergeant Pierce like the game sets up
like this bond you have with these other
four soldiers on your squad and this is
what you see in the trailer it's like
you're far away from home far away or
farm boy farm boy like welcome to the
first infantry and it just felt out of
place to me where was like did they not
go through training together in the
first infantry like it's just the line
in itself just it's like overly macho
and everything he says just makes me
want to like not play the game to be
honest because I don't know it's it's
such a I mean if I hear the term boots
on the ground one more time I'm gonna
blow my brains out but every time that
they say it's returning to boots in the
ground combat right cuz if in a warfare
I actually think people are forgetting
how decent that story was actually cuz
this game explorers like the toll of
leadership with because sergeant Pearson
Josh T Mel's character and the one
grabbing you right here lieutenant
Turner they have this rivalry which like
it's kind of unrealistic in the sense
that he's a lieutenant and a sergeant is
like pretty much disobeying him all the
time and I don't know why they don't
address that but they're kind of like
this it becomes this tug tug of war
between and someone who cares about the
men and he cares about civilians at
certain points but then starting
Pearson's more by the books just do the
objective poor leadership you think and
then of course they there's this
struggle between those two kind of the
power struggle and I feel like the story
doesn't know whether to focus on that
and they've been saying they want to
make this authentic but I can't tell you
how many QuickTime events there are I
can't tell you how many turret defense
sequences there are it felt like I was
playing not just the return to Call of
Duty World War two but like I was
playing call duty in 2005 it just looked
better yeah it's funny you mentioned the
QuickTime events because we were playing
the call of duty stream leading up to
the announcement for this game there was
like I was playing call of duty
like all these silly quick time events
haha this is such an outdated thing that
games aren't gonna do anymore and then
little do you know they do the same
thing in this game as well and another
thing too that went because I played the
campaign and played it about ten of the
campaign there's just there's too many
moments where like [ __ ] is like too
crazy like well you're one guy like and
there's like trees falling and things
are falling on you but you scape like
the bell tower is one thing I let's not
spoil that but yeah well there is an
underlying sign of it's what you're
saying but yeah sorry no there's just
and then there's uh the Train moments
like I think that's a mission afterwards
it's like there's just too many of these
oh I made it out of the skin of my teeth
or this thing could have fell and kill
me the way if it landed one inch closer
to my brain or something and the fresh
I'm like I agree with you and I'm like
trying to fight that sentiment I feel
like I'm like well you know it is a
video game right like but to what
extreme like do these things and I go
there's there's a zombies mode where
you're fighting undead monsters and it's
scary and it's you know it's corny and
cheesy that's fine because there that's
what they're going for
there's multiplayer which of course is
just gonna be try to like they're trying
to let you have fun with other people
and have the progression and they're not
trying to be authentic but they've said
time and time again that they want to be
authentic in the campaign and they want
to do boots on the ground combat because
other the other teams Treyarch and
Infinity Ward haven't been doing that
that's being a sledgehammer game it's
just so ironic that the reason Call of
Duty was originally formed was because
Vince Zampella and Jason West were upset
with how the Medal of Honor games were
continually going toward this like
secret agent vibe like the superhuman
world war two soldier and they wanted to
go back to that authentic character like
soldiers story called duty to call duty
the first one in 2003 the PC exclusive
those were more about individual
soldiers within this experience you know
going from the British to the American
to the Russian front now in this game
there's like there are spy movie chase
sequences there when you're in the
Battle of the Bulge is here because it's
a world war two game and people someone
said of course that they're gonna tell a
similar story thousands of soldiers had
the same story there are so many
different directions you could have gone
with world
rather than the Saving Private Ryan
story but the the trees like artillery
starts falling what would you do like
what in every single World War two story
we've heard in real life what do people
do they get down as low as they can
because the trees are splintering what
do you do in this game you're like let's
get out of here and you run like a
hundred yards while there's artillery
exploding before us all around you like
they've said that they started this
Michael Condrey and Glenn Scofield are
the head of sledgehammer now they want
to be authentic so much this doesn't
feel authentic doesn't it feels like
they're going back to like the the same
thing that Medal of Honor is doing and
those I like those games I like
frontline when you're kind of like
infiltrating a German base there are
moments in this game where it gets kind
of clever with some espionage stuff but
usually you're private right yeah
yes sorry private channels and you know
yeah like I just say what you're saying
like the the set pieces are so close
together and consistent where it's like
oh you're now you and someone else just
decide to like hop on a Jeep and like
bust through enemy lines Leia like get
the wheel I'm gonna get on I'm gonna
like get on the gunner position and then
like I don't know it's like Indiana
Jones status right where it's like then
like three German jeeps come out of
nowhere and intervene as you're going 80
miles an hour they're on your side's
it's like I don't know if a private in
the US military infantry was was doing
this you'd know about that oh and then
after it's done your your captain's like
hey why don't you get your head out your
ass and start acting like a soldier
you're being like a wuss right now and
it's like did you I just saved a
battalion of American troops but anyway
it's a good-looking game as you could
see and I don't want yours harp on the
campaign but even okay I'm sure there
will be people saying it's a video game
they had to make it dramatic I get that
there are better ways to do that eyelid
I count it there are at least ten
QuickTime events where you get in this
melee match Saving Private Ryan like
with this Nazi and you're pressing
square and then you're lining out the
analog stick to press triangle to pull
the pistol out at the last second shoot
them in the face
you're there are these heroic events or
you could save your soul your comrade
it is the most choreographed thing ever
it doesn't feel heroic there's this
countdown dial that if you don't shoot
the Nazi bite he'll kill your friend
right and even that feels out of place -
because moments before when I'm actually
playing the game I have eight of my
fellow comrades right behind me yeah and
then it's just this lengthy 20-second of
me you know yes as you mentioned same
program trying to prevent a knife from
going in me it's like literally two feet
away or even my friends what are they
doing also how also hey Jefferson how
did you get into this bunker we just it
was locked and we blew it open what were
you doing here before the invasion
espionage yeah are you on the Nazi side
should I be saving you like how did he
get in here I don't know that's being
harsh but I think I am - not even a fun
game I don't think it's not a fun
campaign
there are QuickTime events there are
turret defense sequences so okay people
will say you don't have to use the
turrets if I have to choose between m1
garand where I'm defending a wave of
Germans approaching this farmhouse and
this artillery why would I not use this
30 Cal machine gun right next to me but
it feels like a game that came out in
2005 it looks like a modern game it
feels like a World War 2 game I could
have played 10 years ago and I wanted
them to you know like I think going back
to World War 2 at this point in time
there's a high bar to meet it's not a
it's not Christopher Nolan was working
this movie and maybe it's unfair to
compare it but like Dunkirk did
something different recently that was
less a war movie about like battles and
actual camaraderie there's more about
the anxiety and I mean this is kind of
this happened way earlier but like you
look at Band of Brothers or not Band of
Brothers I mean that is a good exam
to like those told very good stories at
least at the time from what I remember
enjoying those stories quite a bit and
they felt grounded boots on the ground
fish I don't yeah
he's sorry he is almost identical to
Colonel sink from banner brothers you
know who was a real person and right and
they were gonna prepare a brother stuff
of this they even say the whole Company
of Heroes thing and then toward the end
of the game won't spoil anything but
when you start to realize the story
there's like this personal narrative
that has to do with dreams and stuff it
starts to come full circle and as if we
didn't get it what does
the main character saying his voiceover
seems like everything's coming full
circle you guys get that point my the
only one yeah don't
it's I wouldn't recommend it I I like
the opening I I thought it was cool I
like being back on Normandy we haven't
seen it in a long time and singing in
this new engine I thought I thought was
pretty stunning but yeah I think right
when I finally hit the ground and
started playing it was like okay yep
I've seen this I don't know if I need to
see more of this yeah and I guess
because because yeah I mean like you
know not to rag on the game so much like
I wonder if it's if it's the sentiment
that like I think you might you to Mike
have like or anyway everyone here like
what I know of like like the world war
ii like the media that this game like
really seems to be influenced by i'm
yeah but we mentioned savor i Ryan ban
brothers but those are really like
intense and heavy films and and episodes
of TV show like yes it to pull from that
and then have these crazy and pass them
Bassett
you know Uncharted esque like set pieces
it it feels like that's fighting itself
in that respects likening it's hard it's
hard for me to like go for one second
and see the horror of war right in the
beginning on the beach mean there's just
like like just limbless dude and then to
go to a different like really fun car
chase it just it feels like they don't
sync up and that's what I feel like I'm
fighting but you know what if you don't
know those movies and those inspirations
like maybe you will have a great time
playing this camp if you're like 18
today maybe this is your biggest most
exposure to world war 2 right d-day to
you know to the Battle of the Bulge to
crossing the Rhine and maybe this is in
in this K in that case I would just
think a watch band of brothers same
program they're easily available but I
don't know there are less cliched ways
of looking at World War 2 from the
American standpoint at least and this is
all an American camp well no not true
there are a couple parts where it
branches off to other characters who are
not American but by and large is about
the American campaign starting with
Operation Overlord and zombies is dope
though yes I like
yeah let's talk about so okay I will say
there's not much to talk about
multiplayer but I think that's actually
a good thing
wouldn't you say say they went back to
the ground they got rid of you know like
a wall running and traversal and the
exosuits they replace those with
divisions kind of these creative class
that specific kinds of characters that
get specific abilities like the
paratroopers will have a suppressor they
can attach a suppressor they're done
here you got a goddamn [ __ ] loot
crate's of course but anyway there's the
headquarters they're kind of pulling
from destiny in the whole social aspect
of it right they've got the headquarters
I don't care about that it's just kind
of filler between the missions what mode
is that mode live now it didn't have
trouble at launch there there yes
actually there I think the most server
issues with a call duty since like that
whole battlefield 4 year alright and
2013 was it mistaken but by and large
the muliplayer is great the map design
it varies actually there are some maps
that are my least favorite in the series
but there's something really cool very
good Maps the USS Texas is really good
the the yeah there's that one I think
there's that huge like Train thing in
the center and basically you can see all
of the map yeah it like it kind of
abandons that whole three lane approach
that I mean it's still there but it's
like not nearly as strictly defined as
many Call of Duty maps are now yeah and
it does feel like like some of the
better ones are kind of that lame based
I think that Call of Duty has gone
towards stands like modern warfare 2 I
would say but it is fantastic map design
I think if you're one of the people I
think like the majority people who get
this game not for the campaign but for
multiplayer yeah get this game it's it's
great it feels like it used to just
better there's no more traversal there
aren't any infinite warfare
advanced warfare kind of exosuits stuff
there are divisions it is very more it's
very much more pulled back which I think
it benefits from and but while we're on
the topic of multiplayer we can talk
about the co-op zombies which speaking
of destiny feels like a raid in the
objectives you're doing Jake can you
kind of explain zombies to us as far as
yeah so I think I mean the first thing
that I noticed was different was that I
go to a window to repair it and you
can't
which seems which is just crazy because
you you've been able to do that
every zombie map up until this point but
yeah it's save one and makes money like
put up all those boards but yeah it it
still is wave base there's still tons of
zombies that are gonna be rushing you
once you hit like the later waves it's
really tough but yeah it is kind of like
a raid in a sense where you are given
objectives and they're not as like
obscure as they were before I'd say like
a lot of times would be like yeah here's
the objective but we're not really gonna
tell you how to do it you just have to
explode the map and figure it out which
was cool
but this is definitely more focus like
you can check objectives and you have to
work as a team in order to push those
objectives forward like for example kind
of early on there's one point where
there's two switches on opposite sides
of the map and I think if you're by
yourself you're given more time to hit
both those switches but if you're
playing with friends you have less time
so I was playing with Nick and he was
like all right you wait here I'll go
here and he's like all right I pulled
the switch then I pull the switch and
it's like alright now we gotta meet in
the center of the room and we have to
activate this machine so we activate the
machine this red circle goes around and
we're like all right we have to power
the machine by killing zombies within
this circle once we're done with that we
move and we made it up to the giant
blimp that floats around the area which
is not the end apparently it's very long
yeah but it is like it almost feels like
a boss like this entire time you have
this blimp flying around kind of raining
hell down on you unless you know how to
deal with it which we finally forgot how
to deal with it however we died but yeah
as someone who's played pretty much
every single game for the zombies mostly
I mean not mostly but like that is a
huge part of why I play Call of Duty I
think this is the first one I've gotten
into in a while just because they it
still keeps that formula but it does a
lot of little different things like it
focuses more on objectives it there's
feels like there's more progression as
opposed to just you know grinding to
higher waves you gotten sick of doing
the same objectives in the same order on
repeat playthroughs cuz I've only played
it like twice so I've only done it a
couple times and I have a feeling this
will be an issue eventually because in
like in previous zombies you kind of
touched on this but those objectives
were optional right like you could do
those if you you can do certain
objectives if you wanted to get like the
power weapon or the Makah punch machine
this you actually to progress to certain
areas you need to turn the power on a
certain way so yeah there's a point
where you don't have to anymore like
what you do sorry you do that in the
other games but still this one even more
so you literally can't get past like the
second area at all but it's pretty easy
to do that though I'd say cuz like there
is a point where you can just start
ignoring objectives and you'll have the
whole map open for you but yeah I mean I
could see how it gets get old after a
while they did they did do certain
things to kind of like change it up like
there's a series of switches you need a
hit and the order changes and the
sequence changes okay well that's that's
nice at least if it's not the exact same
thing like you know in other zombies
just like you have a you have multiple
doors you can open up at any given time
yeah the branches right it needs to and
figuring out that like the waypoints is
that kind of the same where it's like oh
it's easy to do like you know I feel
like some bees you want to develop a
circle system you know just like being
able to always move in fire while
running backwards well also like there
are certain areas that will have the Box
when it moves the RAM weapon box so you
do have to learn the map for sure and
here you see the mines underneath the
cab yeah and when I say like objectives
like it doesn't like give you like a
marker like this is where you need to go
okay it kind of it still kind of obscure
and then it'll like that for example you
you don't necessarily know where that is
you kind of have to explore figure that
out and there's another point where you
have to hit these switches in a certain
order and you're giving this map in
German and it just numbers it just puts
numbers down it and like if you don't
know the map like I think Ben and some
people in the office we're doing it and
it took us like probably 20 minutes to
figure out where all that stuff was me
you yeah it took us a while to figure
out all that stuff was which it's so
cool because it has that aspect of
discovering or self-discovery
but it also has a more directed
experience for those yeah when you said
objective like the objectives were on
the we're in the game like but tell you
where to go but they don't I just saw
one right it was just like find the
second power supply so it's like okay
well at least we know what we're looking
for
okay and and that's hidden in the map so
that's that's nice it's also a little
bit more forgiving like you have I think
they added the
our powers before but you also can take
way more hits than before which at first
I was like alright this is kind of like
it's no longer the two three hit rule
where you get knocked down come with ten
but exactly but it like and that's what
it makes sense considering that yeah I'm
so frustrated if you were dying that
easily when you're trying to do all
these objectives um I love call duty
zombies so much they had the Chronicles
pack that came out earlier this year the
black ops 3 chronicles back oh there was
a lot of that yeah it was from world at
war I mean cuz the original one knocked
our antonin from world at war the when
you beat the game it just rolls and you
like what the hell is this that came out
after the first horde mode and gears war
- if I'm not mistaken but still before
like all these zombie games came out and
all these horde modes came out and I
still like they've always just made it
interesting and fun like you don't have
to be authentic like this there's
zombies it's fun as hell and it's it's
um it's one of the better co-op
experiences that I've ever played you
know like zombies lend themselves well
to co-op games left 4 dead is one my
favorite games but it's I like the
chronicles pack is well worth getting if
you don't have that the DLC that came
out earlier this year for black ops 3 I
I can't say enough about call duty
zombies even infinite warfare is the 80s
based one and then the 70s was it those
ones are really fun I will always play
call duty zombies and I get annoyed with
the actors coming into it but whatever
it's it's fun like Marcellus Wallace is
in this yeah III think another thing
James you mean yes boss about to go MIDI
wrong I think another thing that I do
like about this is the map isn't huge
like it's you're not like exploring a
giant map which is cool in a sense but
it's really nice to have him more
contained
contain map to and to play in rather
than like I think it was like black ops
2 or something that had that one where
you have to take a bus through the
entire place and it's like alright I
don't know where any of these places are
yeah I I don't I love the better maps
and zombies they're fantastic and this
one this one I'd say is a parish I think
for me personally I'm curious if it will
just wear thin after subsequent
playthroughs but so if
I'm having fun with it so that's called
Judy World War two
I don't know we if there's much more to
talk about we talked about the campaign
multiplayer multiplayer they just
brought stuff into the division it's not
the same pick ten system anymore but
it's still very fun multiplayer it's
kind of a return to like the classic
Call of Duty without movement without
kind of parkour stuff if you'd say I
don't know did you play much multiplayer
in this yeah I played a lot of the
multiplayer as well and I mean you
always play Call of Duty's each year or
I fell off their black ops one and I
kind of like dipped in here and there
but uh going back to the multiplayer I
think that it was like oh I kind of
missed this and then after a few hours
like okay I get it
yeah I think it's it's more it less has
to do with the game because I think that
the multiplayer is it's well built in
the sense that it's there's a lot
there's a lot of things supporting it
like with the divisions and like the
attachments that aren't there not too
overtly like game changing they they fit
the tone of the game I mean you know
you'll have like red dot sights and
stuff like that but they're not like
they're not it doesn't look
anachronistic while you're playing so it
makes sense visually in there so that's
not jarring then the warm war modes cool
I mean mouths [ __ ] yeah talk about the
warm out-cook I don't think we did for
people don't know yeah it's an objective
base style multiplayer which has been
done before obviously with with
operations in battlefield one I think
that you know Call of Duty's taken this
in colony he's done this style of stuff
before I was an assault mode back in the
day I couldn't really I might be missing
naming that yeah they have it but they
they do a fairly I think it's it's
well-built it's like the one the one map
the snow map where you're yeah if you're
pushing three tanks you gotta get at
least two and then you move on to the
next objective like those things are
really cool because it's it's chaotic
you know you're trying to flank enemies
constantly while pushing objectives and
I was like oh yeah this is this is
really cool this is well-made but I
think for me personally it's just I'm
not really into multiplayer anymore that
much so I did I played like ten hours
and it's like okay yeah I like this this
is good but I have I got my fill yeah
and I think if you've been like burnt
out on shooters it's not really gonna
change your mind yeah
but if you are wanting to get into more
boots on the ground multiplayer this is
this is a good one but I've like I said
I've had my fill you started that I said
don't say it you tell us not to do
something we gonna do it if you wanna if
you my go more in depth at Mugello
concepción did I review he that's up on
GameSpot obviously he's not here we have
very different opinions from one person
to the next about any game like we're
not we don't all get together in room
and score a game if you think that's how
it works and that's dumb
but anyway yeah so got called 2d World
War 2 is out now you can go play it very
good multiplayer zombies different
thoughts in the campaign but to each
their own
so let's move on to Star Wars
Battlefront 2 multiplayer specifically
the embargoes up single-player I don't
think you play but we also can't talk
about it yet I think we can now cuz it
is on early access or not early access
it is all the whole campaign no no just
the first three missions you guys played
anyone I fir context it was this morning
so on early access but I can give you my
impression of the first like 5 minutes
they can compare our impressions the the
little snippet clip of the cinematic
remember that where she's talking to her
her father I didn't there's it it starts
off with a lot of that feel and that
like it seems very much like a Star Wars
game even like like the cinematics like
like it feels at home it's it's I'm
engaged like right off the bat but yeah
we don't really have much say oh that's
a player yet because yes right now you
can if you have a PC or Xbox one and you
have the EA Origin access you can play
the first or play for 10 hours but our
style front to and as Jake said the
first three mission so we'll be doing a
lot of that today and on a stream later
at 1 p.m. Pacific right after this but
yeah but Rock comers Rob handler you
went down to EA Redwood Shores to play a
day of elephants who's multiplayer yeah
much has been said about this game you
know unfortunate or not it was largely
negative because of the whole lootcrate
was this game pay2win system we will get
to that now that you actually had your
hands-on time with the final build of
the game or at least in the review
environment but overall what are your
kind of broad impressions before we dive
into it of the multiplayer in Star Wars
Battlefront 2 compared to the last game
it is better gameplay the feel the look
the classes having a role in the game
you feel like you're part of the team
and they've made the changes yeah this
is me playing this was the first match I
played and I went uh it was MVP it was
like like 38 kills I just liked how
instead of shooting that guy your
instinct was to toss a grenade at his
stomach literally I was like trying to
get a feel for it but anyways yeah like
it you can see there this the squad
iconic I'm getting two times the
experience when I'm playing with my
teammates and the beta they didn't
really have any clear distinction
between like who was in your starting
spawn squad or not everyone's a blue
icon so now they're yellow so you can
differentiate with that because as you
know clones and battle droids look a lot
alike
so like the changes they've made from
the beta seem pretty just and like and
they definitely like implemented
feedback in that respect again like the
you know the the active reload on
blasters each gun feels unique I didn't
get to play so there are two days in the
preview event or reqest review
multiplayer event all starters said in
the end you were a they they said okay
we're gonna unlock all the cars so you
can get a feel for all the weapons and
stuff and he said there was this really
awesome like anti-tank rifle that you
could have for the specialist which is
just like an explosive round like really
long cooldown and everything but you
showed me and it looked absolutely
insane double-barrel shotgun it's
holding this yeah that's like a
secondary for the assault class which is
right here which is like a shotgun and
that's that's on a cool-down ability so
yeah oh yeah the classes feel distinct
I'm excited to play with friends and
like you know like I'll be an officer so
I can like give you guys buff and health
like boss people around boss people
around with a pistol like it seems like
very much a great improvement from the
last game Matt oh and God man star
fighter mode is the [ __ ]
hi I was watching some footage I had a
blast with that mode like is it still um
yes you know so there's also galactic
assault which is where you can like you
know there's Kashyyyk which was a map
there
each planet can have different like
areas for different types of modes so
that was strike where it's just kind of
more objective like hardpoint just
infantry and then there's you know the
map can open up and it's you know yeah
air tanks this is some of the
dogfighting on Kamino Kamino is the same
deal where it's like this is just the
specific star fight I'll star fighter
assault mode where it's just aerial
combat and it feels freakin awesome
and it looks awesome this is this was my
favorite right here you know you have
like really great map design here which
was not present for the aerial stuff
while in the last game in that you
you're given a bunch of obstacles so
some guys on your six you can fly but
you know beneath all these structures
and like weave in and out of like
columns and pillars and get him to like
crash and or hit the waves like there's
so much to be said about this mode I
think it's so much fun and of course the
biggest gripe was the controls last time
we fight about deaths super vanilla last
time and I was just doing the same thing
over and over and I was always shooting
or yeah I don't it didn't feel like
there was much nuance to it yeah you're
right and and and this you know every
one of these Starfighter modes woo pro
status in Starfighter mode here yeah
you're dealt with a bunch of different
objectives so here it's like you know
defend the clone
stars Troyer's from bombers and if they
get past that and do enough damage then
it's like prevent them from blowing up
the shield generator so there's the you
know the shield's go down and then they
attack the engines so there's like a
bunch of series objectives and each map
feels like there's a many different ones
it's fresh I really enjoy it but again
the controls like having the and you can
you can leave kind of the previous
controls where it's like auto roll but
now you have
so you can actually like do a barrel
roll right here like ro you use me yeah
but you know they had criterion Studios
like rework all the flight controls and
it feels awesome and I don't stick for
this there's not that deep you know it's
weird with like dice is like the
joystick support always rolls out really
late so I'll have to see but even with
controller it's it's great and you can
change the style so you can you know you
can have roll on the right with pitch or
you can have you know I don't have to
get into a different game spot that was
a house on dress yeah before we get into
like progression and whatnot because
that's been on a lot of people's minds
what do you do see this having a longer
tail than the first battlefront in 2015
yeah absolutely um might hold your
interest longer I think so if just SAR
fighter mode it was really fun compared
to the last game where it was such a
letdown because I'm the big star Wars
fan
more specifically just starships my god
they're so cool-looking
does having the clone war content in
this game help out the variety whereas
there was just the oh absolutely
original trilogy in last game yeah
absolutely and and just how many
different there you know there are even
more specific different types of air
vehicles right your fighters you have
bombers you have interceptors which all
have different roles so yeah that's
that's great as well I think yeah and
how many different types yeah like not
just Clone Wars the first order granted
they're pretty much this exact same tie
fighters but they're different like
there's like a the interceptor first
order TIE fighter has like an ability to
like turn the back gunner on from member
force awakens how Finn was in the back
of that one so you could like engage
that and you know mess with the guy
who's chasing you there's just a lot
more going on and yeah it feels and
looks awesome
cool just to now I guess Phil Ellie and
the YouTube chat was saying do you need
a card to get into a vehicle so I guess
that's as good of a segue as any how
does the progression work because much
has been made about EA changing things
up after the criticism from the beta
because of the star cards and feeling
like this game was pay to win now so you
spent the day with it
you know what level your character got
to because I know there's some you can't
equip epic cars and so you get to level
20 correct okay here we go so yeah this
is like one of the most confusing
systems as far as per crash how to
progress in this game I don't quite
understand yet like I have to look into
it to see what is the the best way to do
it and how do i how do i cuz you know
you should you should be able to play
and as I said this is something they
address you should be able to play a
class I want to level up assault that's
what I want to do and so that's what I
did when I first went there as I played
about forty five to thirty minutes of
assault and I ranked my class specific
rank not my overall rank went from like
zero to one in that amount of time now I
went out this is my own experience this
is what happened and I still have to
understand if this is exactly what this
all means I'm enjoying this I went out
and I opened up a bunch of loot crate's
to which I had enough credits from the
matches to open up like two to three I
got a card that was one tier level up so
it was like two notches on the card that
was specific to specialists I put that
card on to the specialist class which I
have yet to play not uh not one second
and I got that class rank to four okay
without doing anything but opening up a
lucrative
I have to be ranked 5 in order to unlock
the ability to have a second card slot
and then 10 in order to do that 10 I am
when I'm at level 10 I can to my
understanding I can then then is the I
have the ability to use crafting parts
to upgrade any star card I want okay you
want the epic card which previously in
the beta the was the only way to get one
of those the best card right which have
like unique abilities you could only get
those through opening a loot crate now
the only way you can do it is through
crafting parts from upgrading an epic to
a legendary whatever like system they're
calling these things but sorry legendary
to epic I believe I don't know what the
I don't even know if they're calling
them what the highest card is called is
it softening so I was reading that in
order to craft certain weapons you have
to get like reach certain milestones
like get 50 kills with this class
and cetera human players not AI because
there's AI everywhere but yeah human
players and then to get the next tier
weapon for said class pursuit of class
it's a hundred and then it's two hundred
okay so that can take a while it might
you may think it doesn't but it can take
a while but so you could not so you
would need to get that hundred kills of
that class you couldn't just buy a crate
and get that level of tier of weapons so
weapons are everything you can you can
get in the game you can get in the loot
crate except for these the best cards
okay that sounds fair
so I'm just saying that sure but I told
you that scenario and from the beta loot
crate's now costs or credits wise which
is like the in-game currency like up to
2000 credits in order to open up a loot
crate now here is what I found today is
the not credits or crystals crystals are
different from credits oh yes crystals
are where you put your money into and
you can open up crates so it costs about
anywhere from 200 to 110 crystals to
open up one loot crate so we did the
math you can see there in the far right
you get for $100 or $90 if you are
subscribed and pay the origin access fee
you get 60 loot crate's is basically a
match the math if you're opening up only
troop trooper crates trooper crates are
only you know that's where you get all
the class specific infantry star cards
and their star fighter which is like I
don't know 150 I don't know for the
crystals so that's where the money is
now there's also the thing to be said
about loot crate's is that like I know
there are a lot of weird frustrating
things about this game where you're
you're playing a game and you get a
milestone and then you you are the only
way to open up a loot crate or redeem
milestones and rewards is by exiting the
game and going into like the menus and
then
a blue Kris you're just always being
forced out to like into the Luke rate
area and that's really frustrating to
like get something and then have to quit
a game it takes time it's frustrating
but it's you can't look any other way
was just like I'm being just so directed
into this this lootcrate system it's
nonstop and it's frustrating I mean I I
feel like I'm just rambling because I
have so many mixed opinions about like
how how frustrating it is like you know
somebody is gonna do the math on like
I'm like okay I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna spend any money
what is that timeframe like it's going
to be long because so it's a one last
thing is that so if I want to level up
my epic card I need to have crafting
parts right mm-hmm those raise so
exponentially where it's like if it's
from the beta it's like 480 crafting
parts you're opening up a crate and
you're getting like I got I opened up
one just now because I was playing a
little bit it's like five five crafting
parts in one crate like eventually it's
gonna take you like you know like two to
Luke rates at like I for playing a
couple matches I don't know like the
speed in which you're getting crafting
parts is just gonna take so long and
there's always that nagging thought of
like someone paying money and just
opening up a bunch of loot crate's
I know so it's there it's it's there's
not much to say like so even with Call
of Duty World War two you have it takes
a lot of time to unlock everything right
and then the loot crate's themselves you
can get loot crate's but those who
creates only contribute to aesthetic
stuff whereas called you you're kind of
getting a constant stream with actual
unlocks here the actual unlocks are
actually randomized and put in the Aleut
crates so oh thank you
now you're gonna have an ex gripe okay
so I'm just enabling him right now you
are I hope I'm being coherent because
it's like so like it's so I've been
investing coffee into his thigh to
so so many times I opened a blue crate
and this is at this event where like I
opened up one I wanted you know you're
hoping for like a cool starfighter thing
or like if I open up a hero crate and I
open up hero crate and I get I got like
three things I got maybe five crafting
parts a Darth Vader emote or sorry
victory emote and then maybe some
credits like a thousand credits a Darth
Vader it's you know you start the game
like six heroes are locked and require
progression to which I I'm not quite
sure maybe it's like you know 200 kills
as a hero which is freaking ridiculously
hard right I'm opening up something and
I'm getting a card that I can't use for
a hero that's by chance if I can get to
play him and by chance if I win a match
and I'm MVP then I get to see that card
in effect you have to be MVP with that
character it's a victory pose I have to
I have to have the most kills have to
have an MVP award or like most damage or
objective points that's the only time I
get to see that card damn how is this
Luke rate fun in any way or like sick
cool like it's just like like I heard
some another guy the event said he
opened up one and had a similar thing
but like he was given a thousand credits
and it was a card that he couldn't use
so it's like cool
I just gave like you know over 2000
credits and I got a thousand credits
back like that just feels like like
you're just barely treading water you're
even going back downstream guides lost
thousands of credits mm-hmm you got to
play really well in order to get a lot
of credits to you know like if I play
like if I'm at the bottom a little of
the match because I suck you're getting
like you know I don't know less than a
thousand credits so overall it sounds
like battlefront 2 is well designed in
its gameplay and whatnot but it does
still feel like a lot of the progression
elements are confusing to the point that
it's really encouraging you to pay or at
least spend an inordinate amount of time
to get better abilities yeah like I
could have you I mean for them
part of what I just said as far as like
the examples in like costs and currency
like I've that's I'm fairly sure all
that is accurate but again like these
systems are so confusing and they're so
hard to like to just understand that I
don't know like Alessandro who's
reviewing the game he was like what do
you think of this game he's like it's
really fun like the progression or I'm
sorry that the gameplay is really fun
but he's like I've never seen a
progression system so like sounds
convoluted its convoluted yeah and and
just baffling where it's like why is
this so confusing like it's and it's
confusing the sense that the information
is just not provided like I just like
the game should I have a phat tutorial
like video like here's how it's gonna go
down buddy
watch this [ __ ] you get it just like I'm
like dude I have a calculator in my
hands like looking at like what's the
price for a loot crate I got a no you
have to go to Dagobah so Yoda can teach
you how micro transactions work in this
game
that'd be cool that suck that's a cool
idea it's a shame because this game
sounds fun outside of all of this messy
microtransaction loot crate progression
problems and they could patch it later
on someone mentioned plants vs. zombies
garden warfare same thing happened but
then they implemented the opposite it
kind of made it a little shady er so
here's hoping they keep tweaking it over
the coming months this game releases
Friday right or next week next Friday
the 17th yeah you know 17th the same day
we start an extra life okay yeah you
know what else is interesting too is
like you know just because it was nice
to compare loot crate's because there's
so many other games that have loot
crate's overwatch maybe you guys could
help me out about the the most you can
pay it was it it's like $40 for Oh
hey he's gonna have tell me out it's
like $40 for 50 flight all $40 for 50
credits crates $20 for 50 crate that's
like compared to $100 20 compared to
$100 10 $100 to 60 crates and in the
description and overwatch it says
guaranteed for items mm-hm
I was opening crates and I was getting
two items and I was getting up to four
items nice yeah two items overwatch
works out to like a dollar ten per crate
and you're getting four items they could
be tubes but oh and dupes changed too
they had said earlier the dupes would be
turned into crafting parts not anymore
there turns into credits crystals or
credits credits meaning what do you do
with credits you're opening up more loot
crate's okay interesting what are you
gonna say something Jake no please in
the chat or comments below if if there's
anything I misspoke on I would really
like those comments to surface up the
top berserker oh is correcting my math
it's I was gonna say I need sound
writing eighty cents less than a dollar
eighty seven or greater ninety something
whatever that's why I don't spend money
on these things cuz I'm not good enough
at math to buy
listen smash back three as we found out
this morning yeah I was telling about
the first instance of loot crate's that
I ever experienced was Mass Effect 3 and
I actually spent like 100 total dollars
on that holy I was young enough to do
that and I it was also the first game I
ever saw it with so I didn't realize I
was being exploited so there you have it
you can blame me for this whole loot
crate thing over the years darling that
guy we got them to spend a hundred that
extra dollars on Mass Effect 3 yeah and
then DB addict and twitch I was also
saying Woodward Wales yeah there will be
people don't spend a lot of money bail
front two unfortunately I want to know
something that we're gonna blows of you
watching air Tay and I are going to be
streaming Balfron at 1 p.m. Pacific in a
bilang everybody and we're gonna we're
gonna know for science we're gonna we're
gonna do with $100 we're gonna test it
I'm not I'm not gonna be happy how much
of a waste of money it was I had 1 p.m.
Pacific we're gonna do $100 and see what
happens okay cool and progress carries
over for the origin trials so thank God
so that would be 1 o'clock Pacific
you're gonna start opening crates with a
hundred Rebecca so I want to play a
campaign to like you know cushion the
frustration okay cool we'll have a loot
crate extravaganza with a hundred
dollars US dollars at one o'clock
Pacific on gamespot twitch YouTube and
our site channel alright finally Michael
hi I'm yo one of our resident tech
experts who I don't know if I'd say yeah
um I hope you are we're paying you to be
next box one X came out yesterday it
sure did Jake you got yours in the mail
and everything Nick got his but we've
had it for a couple weeks I think
Microsoft was gracious enough to send
one to the UK office in here people kind
of it seems to be a bit of a wet fart as
far as the interests around it you know
kind of faded out I would say but I'm
excited for because you know like this
is kind of the new thing like ps4 pro
comes out it's the console updates the
iterative thing that you know PCs are
always doing and not to that extent yet
but who knows down the road um so far
broad strokes Xbox one X what is it
doing for Microsoft what's it doing for
the console market in general right now
um so first off yes it is the most
powerful console that there is but I
think that I mean I'll just say this off
the bat is that you know when you when
you go into a Best Buy or at our game
you want to buy a TV everything's gonna
be the things that are gonna be on
display are all 4k or 4k and HDR
best-case scenario right that you could
have as a setup yeah yeah so like 1080p
TVs are like stuffed away in the corner
like they don't want you to see that
like I was in the Best Buy like not too
long I was like you know I'm about to
get a 1080p TV where y'all have that and
like they looked at me like I'm a
dumbass that way we're in the trash
in the basement you gotta fight past six
alligators together yeah and so and
looking at the Xbox one the original
Xbox one hardware is it's really weak
and like not all games even did 1080p
like a lot of games had to do 900p and
then upscale so what this I think what
this does for Microsoft is saying that
you know if everyone's gonna be getting
like 4k TVs and you know all these games
gonna be pushing like graphical quality
and stuff we need a system that can at
least push that out or handle that at
least that's how I see it because if the
ps4 pros out there like intervals
everyone's like an Xbox one it's like
well I'm not gonna get this
I might not get this weak piece of
hardware especially if I'm gonna if I
want I mean Xbox 1s does HDR but when
you get 4k it really exemplifies the
benefits of HDR so I think that's what
you're getting out of it and you know
for people who are in the Xbox one
ecosystem you know this is a this is
something for them to look at and say oh
okay like Microsoft is there they're
doing something new they're they care
about like you know power and they want
games to be looking great on their
system because you know if you look at
what comes to load times and just
overall visual fidelity on Xbox one I
mean some of that stuff looks rough you
know like Wolfenstein Wolfenstein new
Colossus one just came out you know
playing on Xbox one original like the
load times are bad and that game looks
blurry blurry as hell and so you know
you don't wanna you don't want a console
existing console to be putting out games
like that you don't want that to be like
your marquee a piece of hardware so then
you know that's where the Xbox one next
steps in and I think it's necessary it's
not for me I've always said this like
you know as a PC gamer you have to think
about the talk target audience and then
you kind of do these filters it's like
okay do you have a gaming PC check then
this isn't for you or you'd even care
about the Xbox one ecosystem No then
this isn't for you
but if you are in in that market then
this is this is a great piece of
hardware in terms of implementations go
its inconsistent which you would kind of
expect during launch you know not every
game that says it's going to be Xbox 1 X
enhanced is enhanced yet there's a lot
of you can go on the Microsoft website
and see the games that are enhanced and
you'll see a bunch of games that are
either says in development or in
progress
you know developers are making these
patches because they have to put in the
effort to have their games run properly
with on this new hardware but we did we
did see some some games running with a
with 1x enhancements like Gears of War 4
and it looks dope
it looks great runs great and you also
have the choices you'll have some cases
you'll have choices - for like
performance mode where I can get like I
can get 60fps and stay at 1080p or I can
do 4k at lower frame rate so you have
those options as well so it's it's not
too dissimilar to the ps4 pro honestly
it does have a little bit more power it
will be pushing out higher res but in
terms of how its implemented with
patches and having your options it's
very similar to the ps4 Pro it's yeah
it's it's a good system but if you if
you care about Xbox then you'll probably
care about this otherwise like cool like
it's another system yeah if you have you
played many games on it yet no I played
gears or for super luckiest it does look
really good there were some cases where
it was even looking like better than PC
these games yeah cuz we yeah we were
looking at that and I my question is
it's weird is it almost like - good like
did they do they do something to the X
version cuz I want to say it's like not
remodeling but like retexture an even
yeah yeah so like it's up to devs what
they do with this hardware so they can
like for example in Gears or for I'd say
someone like the textures lighting
shadowing looks better than PC ultra
because I I think that they've done like
went above and beyond in terms of like
those graphical features coalition is
also a first-party studio so it makes
sense that they're really of course yeah
they want to like it does the best
product of course and yeah it looks
great
you know and it's about looks better
than PC version it doesn't run quite as
well if you have if you have like a
super dope PC of course you're gonna be
getting like 60 plus frames per second
but in terms of like pure fidelity the
Xbox one X version gives over four looks
freaking awesome but if you read digital
of digital foundry put out a story the
other day about titanfall 2 Xbox one X
enhancements and it has
dynamic resolution but it also has other
graphical features on top of that so
what was it what and then they said that
the titanfall to Xbox one X version
started looking worse than the ps4 pro
version because of dynamic resolution
it was dipping to resolutions below what
the ps4 pro would dip to so in that way
the game started to look more blurry at
times yeah at times because dynamic
resolution adapts to what's happening
on-screen so at times it was looking
blurrier than the ps4 pro version and
then so that that kind of begs the
question of like how consistent are
these enhancements gonna be it's hard to
tell and you can never know until the
patch for a certain game comes out yeah
so so available now as of you wrote this
as of November 6th which was two days
ago Monday I'm gonna list some games
that have the updates gears were for
obviously we just saw a killer instinct
we just saw diablo 3 reaper souls
ultimate evil edition LA noire yeah cuz
they did a few Xbox 360 games already
yeah outlast 2 sonic forces hell yeah
transcripted World of Tanks super Knight
Riders and E for speed payback so there
are some games I'd say about 15 right
now that are already updated and then
coming soon is a huge list yeah you know
like Dishonored 2 Assassin's Creed
origins halo 5 halo 3 hello neighbor
which will come out hitman Killing Floor
2 middle Earth's shadow for like all the
games that we were kind of wondering
about like I think I saw Aaron Greenberg
from Microsoft saying within two weeks
of launch there try and get the majority
of those games updated so if you have
one right now if the game isn't updated
already then it should be within the
coming couple weeks I think based on
what they were saying and then in
development there's an even longer list
like obviously doom will eventually get
this and doom hoping to look gorgeous
yeah you know that's coming on the
switch soon but it's also just a
good-looking game far cry 5 when it
comes out fire watch for on or fortnight
Forza horizon 3 halo of Master Chief
collection majority of Xbox one games
that you care about will probably update
it I would say whether it's you know
like going into 2018 or in the next
coming weeks but I am
also optimistic I think it was a
Bloomberg done interview with Phil
Spencer recently said now that the Xbox
1x is out obviously you have teams still
updating and whatnot and you have all
these individual developers updating
their games for that console Phil's
press were saying yeah we've admittedly
not done the best job with first party
exclusives or even third-party
exclusives and now he said they're
turning their attention to software
investing in new studios investing in
existing studios to bring exclusive
stuff than Microsoft console are you
optimistic as far as Xbox is future with
games specifically because that's been
the story with Xbox last year and a half
two years then where all these
exclusives you know PlayStation 4 Pro is
not as powerful but they do have a
decent amount of exclusives and you know
I don't want to just beat up on xbox for
its lack thereof but it's good to know
at least Phil Spencer and the Xbox team
recognizes that and they're trying to
take steps now that they're hard new
hardware is that you should rectify that
software situation obviously you don't
have the inside knowledge of someone
working at Xbox or at least if you did
you can talk about a playoff are you
optimistic about Xbox future now that
this is out do you think it's that big
of a change what do you think it means I
well I think it opens the door for for
like Microsoft to go out and say hey you
want to develop like stuff for our
system like we got this powerful thing
you can work with and you know judging
from what developers are saying so far
they're saying that it's it's pretty
easy to work with it's not unfamiliar to
them so I think that you know this is
something in their in their back pocket
when they want to go to someone and say
develop for our system and it's like
well check this out we got the Xbox 1x
so it's it's like you know you and I
thought about - and that you can't I
mean you can do it but it's you have a
lot less in your hand when you when you
point to your Xbox 1s as your leading
system it's kind of like well yeah sure
will develop for that but like I mean
when you have something as powerful
powerful as this you know it's something
to show off
it's it's it's what I would pick I mean
Jake you just got yours yesterday it's
probably what I would pick to play like
Assassin's Creed origins on or something
of that sort for because it's
better-looking us densely than ps4 pro
yeah I think what's what I find really
interesting like I got an Xbox 1x
but I during the Xbox press conference
at e3 I think they had like something
like 30-plus Windows and Xbox exclusives
but none of those games felt like they
weren't games like oh I can't wait to
try this out on my xbox 1x they were all
like sort of like art like art driven
you know smaller indie games like
cuphead for example which is a
phenomenal game and then you look at
Sony which has less exclusives but the
ones that are there may be not less
excuse that's why not the right word to
say but like the exclusives that they
have like really push their console for
like horizon for example I've been
playing that and looks gorgeous like I
want something like that on my xbox 1x
like it's cool that there are all these
other exclusives but I think I really
hope soon we get something that really
pushes the power of this console like
seeing Gears is cool seeing that
remaster I never finished that someone
go back and play that looking forward to
pub G hopefully crackdown
yeah crackdown 3 turns around yeah yeah
I mean what iswhat we all kind of saw no
one that was it was a little look a
little like I don't know stiffer dated
yeah and that game as is like this the
art style doesn't necessarily I don't
look at that and be like ooh now this
game is like great I mean like I'm sure
the destruction and stuff take advantage
of but it doesn't have that look then
like horizon does like oh yeah Last of
Us like it's just really weird that they
just put out this this super high-end
console with 4k visuals and it's the
most powerful console in the world but
there's no new games to really that they
can hang it down
yeah there's no like driving force to go
along with the console yeah and I hope
like after reading that story about how
Phil Spencer is kind of turning more
attention to I hope they're really
focusing on taking risks and making
those like coming up with IPS that are
new and interesting that really pushed
the tech forward rather than just
another Halo and other gears cuz I mean
those games look good no matter what
because they're developed by people who
are familiar with the consoles first
party studios - exactly I mean so is you
know gorilla I think gorillas first
party for Sony right yeah yeah so I mean
it's I'm looking for I hope maybe
they'll with this new shift towards
software they'll establish like a reason
to come specifically to Xbox that you
can't get on PlayStation right it might
look better Assassin's Creed origins
might look better I I don't know if
you're gonna go back and play like some
earlier game like third-party game it'll
look better but I maybe eventually
though establish themselves with their
first part of games outside of Gears of
War outside of Halo I mean like Ori and
the blind or in Ori to where it's called
the whispering willows fantastic yeah
but and I'm hoping they can get more
along those lines like when we first
thought Metro Exodus would actually
exclusive that was huge but it's not it
was just the timed exclusive whatever
and then see if the eaves is coming out
and that looks fun it's not something
again I would hang my hat on like you
said but I'm hoping that this first
party installation there they're
pursuing is going to establish
themselves more as a very viable console
for exclusives that people can come to
you to play Assassin's Creed origin etc
that was the thing with the original
Xbox right is like yeah you can get
these games in other consoles but it's
gonna look the best or like even their
exclusives look phenomenal mm-hmm
back in the day and now like they kind
of straight away from that and now that
they're kind of putting they're putting
their I don't know the phrase putting
all their chips and a stronger more
powerful console I really hope that they
kind of take that throne again and
actually put their push their system to
the limits and we see some really cool
yeah good looking games out of it yeah
because then like mostly we're getting
is high-resolution versions of games and
maybe like a bump in like it's quality
settings which is cool but you know the
when you mentioned horizon zero dawn
it's like the what the guerrilla is able
to do with the regular ps4 hardware and
how great that game looks like though
how great that game looks plays into the
theme of that game like everything else
though I feel like for the Xbox is has
been like it just looks good for the
sake of like trying to look good so yeah
like when you want to go out and try and
obtain new ip's new things to take
advantage of this hardware I want to see
something like that where it's it's
visually striking in a way that plays
into you know its visually striking for
a reason yeah and I am imagine that it's
a huge risk to take that is like
triple-a development for for a system
that frankly just isn't doing as well as
a PlayStation 4 so right
I mean sales aren't gonna be quite as
strong but I think a lot of more people
will adopt the system or who will be
interested if there is a game that you
know like I've said I think a couple
times like puts that system to its
limits mm-hmm I mean it's gonna take a
while though because you know system
doesn't come out and like you're not
gonna see the best thing coming out of
it straight up so I mean if that's their
approach from here on out now that they
have took care of the hardware now they
want to take care of the software I mean
like sounds good to me
um I just want to see what will come out
of it but we'll you know we're gonna
have to wait for that obviously but yeah
it's Xbox one X is its I like I said
earlier it's it's I yeah and also a it's
the everyone or not everyone but people
were kind of expecting this to be like a
native 4k 60fps machine it's like it's
straight up it's not I mean well
developers don't have to make games like
it can be like you're gonna you can make
like a 3d platformer that's gonna run 4k
60fps and what does it mean for its ax
or no for is this 34 K right
37 I can't I can't tell you off this but
once again that is first party right so
they are more familiar that's to be
expected
yeah yeah and then so in games like
Assassin's Creed origins I think is
gonna be 1,800 P upscaled 4k that game
is already really good-looking yeah that
game that game looks great I mean but
again you're not gonna get and it's
running in like 30 frames per second you
know I get 4k 60fps now should shouldn't
have been the expectations to begin with
but yeah it's definitely like doesn't do
that in very few cases it will but yeah
and and I think anthem also is targeting
1800 P upscale checkerboarding and I
mean I'm not picky when it comes to
graphics between I I can tell like
native 4k looks great
18 droopy checkerboarding looks great
too like there's not it's nothing to cry
over like it's that [ __ ] looks till it
looks at opus but so I mean but yeah I'm
excited to see what they do on the
software side now yeah yeah like I'm
optimistic I think maybe now that they
you know like
it's finally fully into Phil Spencer's
tenure at Microsoft he's not like
cleaning up other people's messes now
Xbox 1x was his there moving forward
investing in studios hopefully that
comes to fruition and we can see more
first party titles from them and more to
play than just a few of those first
party titles and those third party yeah
so let's uh close out the show pretty
much so that's xbox one ex horizon zero
dawn frozen wilds battlefront twos not
available yet but it will be on the 17th
star birth battlefront - or you could
play today on early access if you want
to xbox pc es xbox and pc if you have
the origin access yes CA origins or if
you pre-ordered go a game you can play
that three days early so the 14th cool
yeah sweet and like I said we will be
doing more with an Xbox one X on the
site I'm sure in the coming weeks
especially Michael and Jimmy and
everybody maybe will be streaming stuff
with that Rob at one o'clock today
you're gonna be paying $100 to see what
that'll get you in Star Wars Battlefront
twos loot crate system 40 minutes so
yeah you're you're kind of doing God's
work with that experiment so we'll see
what happens you and Ty you're doing
that do we have a giveaway as always
we're gonna get to that right now -
keyboards they are the oh my god Rose
will RK 9000 V - RGB mechanical gaming
keyboard 100% Cherry MX mechanical key
switches a pre-programmed led modes 5
profile settings up to 50 macros for
gaming applications media function
control and key rollover sivasamy Elvis
information basically eye on our site
you can go and the giveaway page will be
up and you can enter there or you can
look for the GameSpot tweet and retweet
it and they'll also have the link to the
site and we'll pick two winners on
Sunday at 5 o'clock p.m. Pacific time
apologies to everybody else outside of
the US but this is us only and then one
more thing I want to reiterate November
17th at noon we're starting our Extra
Life charity livestream for 72 hours
between us the UK and Australia offices
I'll be kicking it off on the first
segment I think Jake you might be on it
Rob you might be on it
I don't remember we'll all be on at some
point yeah you could stop by we're
aiming to raise 15,000 this year I think
we'll we'll match that we'll have
where will I be last year but let people
come across by Russia be I'm surely
drinking some disgusting concoctions for
charity for Sick Children where's my
office money's going to ha that's right
what did you drink last time uh milk it
was a mixture of milk hot sauce soy
sauce jalapeno cream cheese schmear
you did it for a dollar right yeah yeah
like 50 I different no one no one
actually paid me they just told me that
would I was disgusting it's very bad no
salmon flavored schmear that was my idea
I told them to pay yeah edge put a
little bit of his like volcano sauce in
it and then I stirred it so they'll be
fun we're gonna be playing a lot of
different games multiplayer stuff here
you go this guy it's awful photos of us
November 17 12 p.m. Pacific time tight
whoo thanks anyway yes I stopped by good
that'll be the same day Bal front 2
comes out maybe we'll be playing that
but again we're assuming that at 1:00
today and as always thanks everybody in
the back Richard Lee Erik taejeong Luke
sucky Michael hi I'm Jake Decker thanks
for coming on Callie and people
presumably be back next week Rob - I
would assume and as always we'll be back
next Wednesday 11:00 a.m. Pacific here
in San Francisco California we'll see
you then
[Music]